turn your great idea into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether you're showcasing your work or
selling your products any kind of
products they have beautiful templates
and the ability to customize just about
anything so you can easily make a
beautiful website by yourself but if you
do get stuck they have 24/7
award-winning customer support that is
there to help you out
have the squarespace.com slash grace for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain too deep hello and welcome to
another episode of not too deep I'm
grace Helbig today we have Jessica Marie
Garcia with us she is an absolutely
fabulous human woman and you know more
than that an amazing actress and
incredible comedian
she plays Jasmine on Netflix is on my
block which season three is coming out
very soon if it's not out already
there's a very amorphous state in the
air for what it's about to be a release
but you're not gonna want to miss it we
also talked about her responsibilities
in feeling like she is making a
difference in the world of
representation in entertainment and guys
I found my kindred spirit in someone
that loves reality TV as much as I do
this is a really great episode you're
gonna love Jessica
enjoy
[Music]
Jessica thank you so much for being here
thank you for having this is so exciting
cuz I feel like you're an extremely busy
lady right now
oh yeah totes you've been oh no you can
brag about it you've been very busy cuz
I want to talk about all of it I want to
talk about one your stellar Instagram
where you've got so many poses that I
need to learn how to do thank you you've
mastered the smize more than anyone I've
seen it's a it's a special gift Thank
You Tyra but I want to talk about on my
block okay this is kind of like the
biggest thing happening right now
for people that don't know what this
show is how do you describe it oh I
always like to say it's like freaks and
geeks it's the hood okay you know it's
like all of these characters would be
like side characters and so many other
shows right right like now you're
getting to hear their story from like
their mouth so it's it's really exciting
like I'm really honored to be a part of
it it's super cool and your character
now you're an actual like you're your
full full character on the show yes
which I don't know many people they
don't understand that they you basically
get cast as like what's the term I was a
guest star to begin guest and you have a
guest star which will be like kind of a
featured character in one episode and
then you're like either that or a
recurring guest star and names like you
come back and are in a bunch and that's
what I was right for the first season
and then I came back as a series regular
season two - congratulations thank you
was my first one that's so awesome
I've been like dying for that like title
forever yeah what was it like to get
that news oh my god well first of all
like I've been really trying to like
step into my own power like that's kind
of like my mantra these last days thank
you like when that happened or like when
we found out we got a season two I was
like literally in the phone call when
they told me we got a season two I was
like great
can I are you serious right good works
right I just asked for it and they're
like oh yeah I mean well yeah we'll talk
about it yeah for sure and you planted
the seed well I just kept thinking I was
like I need to make Jasmine like
indispensable like I need to like not
just think she's someone that comes in
and is like I've never seen again so I
really tried really hard
well I mean that's also what's so
bonkers right is that when people are
watching the show obviously they don't
know like the behind-the-scenes workings
of how it works so you get your script
and you get like your task and then it's
up to you to be like how can i really
take this script and give it absolutely
everything so that she gets bumped up a
notch and it's funny because i 100% got
that confidence from betch yeah it's
hilarious cuz yeah I was on the same
batch episode with you right yeah you
know we've never crossed paths in that
which is so bonkers to me because even
going through your Instagram and I know
like I'm just like oh these worlds are
so are hovering next to each other yeah
because you've been working with bets
for how long oh my gosh since I think
season two season three like a nurse
that's how did you how did you get
introduced to those girls over there for
those who don't know betches like the
greatest all-female sketch - those work
their asses off they're so freakin funny
they blow my mind when I am around them
they're ready for all that now yes
that's so good such bosses but yeah I
was doing Liv and Maddie on Disney
mm-hmm with Joey Bragg okay his
girlfriend is Audrey would be right and
Audrey and Maddie and Monica are though
like the creators of Bette right okay
cool so all the dots connect yeah it's
so fun yeah when I went over there and
did I didn't really know what I was
walking into it all and then they're
like here's her makeup I think you guys
are so professional it's not so funny I
love that sketch so much you guys set
along crossroads it's it's a lot I love
it they're so great and also I'm just
like so you guys just do everything
yourself yeah they do
everything oh yeah they're literally
writing it while we're like they're
thinking about tomorrow's episodes and
we're shooting like 12 14 pages a day
and for people that don't know that's
like unbelievable you shouldn't be
allowed to do that so those girls like
and they honestly gave me such creative
like but like control like I was able to
really riff I wrote a sketch and that's
what really helped me start writing so
no no no I owe so much to those girls so
that's kind of where you got like I'm
gonna be a badass confident woman and
I'm gonna start like actually realize
that yeah we're like just knowing with
confidence not with arrogance like what
you bring to the
table 1000% like it gave me the
confidence to kind of bring me to the
room I mean I think it's so easy as an
actor to like decide that you're a
casting director right and you get that
you get your sides and you're like this
isn't me this girl would be like this
and do that so then you end up doing
that and there's another girl who lives
that better than you you know what I
mean like that's who they are so it's
like if I had to bring me and what I
would do selfishly yeah for a character
in that room and be like well this is
what I would bring right you might have
other ideas and that's great and that's
then for somebody else but that gave me
the confidence to go no no what I bring
is good what I bring is good enough it
might not be who you want but I'm going
to show you what I would do yeah and
it's also I mean because it's
fascinating that you're an adult woman
playing a high school student adult
woman I'm 21 and so yeah I think a
little bit more perspective from you
because you've lived this age range
you've like you've done it you've felt
it you've had these relationships or
these different sort of relatable
moments probably yeah I think I've gone
to high school four different times but
no it's it's incredible it also like has
allowed me to grow with each character
like I feel like I learned a lot about
myself and who I was in high school yeah
I kind of go through it oh that's cool
jasmine was a little too close to home
yeah oh no she totally is because she
you know she has these walls that she
puts up in order to like you know say
the joke not be the joke right and I
relate to that on so many levels and
that's why I pushed so hard for her to
have you know moments of where you see
where she's coming from where you see
where that like there's so much pain and
so much laughs there's a lot of adult
you know feelings things that are going
on when you put on that persona so I'm
glad that they let me kind of play with
that season - that's awesome because you
don't want someone to just be this
one-dimensional character especially
when you know who those people are right
and you have the ability to make this so
much more special and complex than what
it could be right I mean it's also
because the show feels like it's very
special
it feels like it's it's something that's
really important to a huge fan base that
you know hasn't
shows like this growing up and hasn't
had enough shows like this or told the
right stories and the right ways so
there must be some pressure to to like
keep keep the magic of this show going
no real pressure at all not at all not
at all especially like you know season 3
is like around the corner hopefully no
one's telling us when that date is but I
know I honestly feel like whenever I say
anything that's even like close to
dropping a spoiler like like Netflix
ninjas are just gonna come from the
floor yeah across the street see they
know ya know I'm here everything's yeah
we're all wired yeah I knew it this
table was very special but this season
is crazy
so I'm hoping that the fans just like go
on this ride with us oh that's so cool
how has the fan reaction been because
like you said you started it on what Liv
and Maddie mm-hmm and that's a Disney
series and so yeah this one feels a
little bit more adult yeah and this is
like Liv and Maddie if we were able to
like curse yeah they're very very
different but it's it's so interesting
to be a part of a show where as much as
like Liv and Maddie was like my heart
and I met like my closest friends from
that show but they were all my wedding
like it's Raiders literally where I fish
and that's you know like that was a deep
Disney connection but like with on my
block it it feels like being around a
different kind of family like a family
where you don't have to try so hard to
feel like you fit in that makes people
that just get you from from hell oh yeah
so that feels very very different and
it's just the impact on our fans is just
what I can't even like yeah ever
comprehend the the DMS we get like the
the messages the edits you know they're
because a lot of kids are being able to
see themselves for the first time and
see their their lifestyles for the first
time yeah and their stories and that's
like that's priceless
because we have had to you know see
other people tell stories that are like
similar to us or supposed to be and you
you just can't get those stories correct
if it's not coming from us right so I
feel like in that respect we were a
little different because we had that
creative control as well yeah there have
been times where I'm like Lauren
not saying this and like that's a
discussion that's open and we can have
it that's very cool because like you
know unless you know like things get
interpreted certain ways and you're like
uh-uh
right no I would never say that but that
I'm sure it makes that environment so
much more collaborative and so much more
respectful which you know it has the
trickle-down effect when you watch the
show when you see the fan base of the
show like everyone's just genuinely
supportive it feels like just even
looking at all of your instagrams of
everyone that works on the show it's
like oh you guys you guys seem like
you're a real family off camera we are
and it's such a dysfunctional one too
because like we're not like that family
where we're like oh my god you're the
best and oh my god I love you up my
Jason I swear to God if you just show up
in my house and just knock on my door
expecting me to cook for you like it's
like that like we're way past like take
a cute selfie we're like beating each
other up exactly um
you were also on how to get away with
murder don't don't talk yeah so these
are quite different roles how what do
you do like to prep or shift or even go
into an audition that you're like so
this is a different than what I've been
doing for a second well it actually
feels really good yeah because I feel
like I've trained I went to you know
acting class and did scene study classes
and went to you know performing arts
like magnet you're working yeah so these
are rules like I can't wait to play like
I'm at home watching how to get away
with murder going oh my god if I was in
that scene like if I was doing a scene
by this is what I would do mind you that
all goes out the window and it's
actually happening yeah
it's it's something that I've been like
you know manifesting and praying for my
whole life so it was very important to
me to go you know Jessica you got to do
this for that little girl in that room
you know what I mean like pretending she
was in a scene with Viola like now
you're in it yeah now you got to do it
so it feels great
well you've also with everything you've
been going to more award shows you've
been now
like you're in this world have you had
any bonkers like fangirl moments oh my
god every moment know if you know this
but we sat with the entire cast of shits
Creek or the MTV Awards you did
did you know wait until you got there
that that was about there just saw me
and Jason and they're like she wants
what an insane sentence right I still
can't
I stole the centerpiece off the table
good for you MTV Awards I was like you
know she could have that moment take
this but no just you know being in their
presence was crazy and then we were like
with the Vanderpump people over here I'm
like you know love and hip hop over here
like I was just like reality show junkie
are you okay
when we're gonna take a break in a
second I will talk for 10,000 hours
about everything reality TV okay let's
let's let's all take a collective breath
and we'll be right back with we're not
you deep today we have support from
Squarespace it's time to turn your dream
into reality with Squarespace they make
it easier than ever to launch a passion
project if you're looking to start a new
business or showcase your work do you
want to publish content sell products or
more Squarespace is the tool for you
they have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks so you can easily make a
beautiful website all by yourself they
also have a powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online and analytics to help
you grow your site in real time and
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box so there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever buying domains is
super simple and you can get the help
you need with Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support they
empower millions of people from
designers to lawyers artists to gamers
restaurants and gyms even to turn
great ideas into something real so head
to squarespace.com slash grace for a
free trial and when you are ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain that squarespace.com slash
grace offer code grace deep today we
were support from a company that's here
to support you I'm talking about third
love third love designs with
measurements from millions of women they
have bra styles that are made to fit
your life they have over 80 bra sizes
but know that the only one that matters
is yours and I've talked about my
personal experience with third love
before as a girl that only wear sports
bras most of the time because she values
comfort I can tell you these are the
most comfortable brawls I've ever owned
hands down
they have straps that don't slip they
have tagless labels and they're
lightweight and memory foam cups mold to
your shape plus they have returns and
exchanges that are free and easy in fact
thanks to third loves perfect fit
promise you as a customer have 60 days
to wear the bra wash the bra and put it
to the test and if you do not love it
you can return it and third love will
wash it and donate it to a woman in need
they know that there's a perfect bra for
everyone so right now they're offering
you 15% off your first order go 2/3
love.com slash grace now to find your
perfect fitting bra and get 15% off your
first purchase
that's third love th IRD l.o.v.e comm
slash grace for 15% off today okay we're
back and so what's your go-to reality
television oh I like Real Housewives of
anywhere okay we were just having a very
intense conversation about all of it
right before you got here and I was like
we gotta get this out of our systems
before she gets here cuz who knows if
she likes this or not and now I know
that we're all in a safe space we're
talking about where well I mean
literally all of them we were trying to
go through some of the most iconic
moments trying to recollect them and
it's hard because there's just so many
they're all so good but you were sitting
next to the Vanderpump on my table
yes there was like James was there and
like his girlfriend was at work how was
they yes okay Stassi all of them were
there oh man like I feel like there
might have been like some drama before
because it feel I felt like one like
Stassi came in she was like wait on
sitting at the table yeah I was like
living for it I loved it it was just
like popcorn that's so fantastic do you
watch any of like the reality
competition shows or yes I I love
anything cooking related okay so like
I'll do chopped yeah I'll do nailed it
who or what are the other ones I do like
anything like Top Chef was my jam
oh yeah no are there any reality shows
that you would love to be on I want it
to be on Bad Girls Club for like so long
this time really and then like as I grew
up I was like no Jessica you can't do
that but I do have a sweatshirt I have
yeah I stopped you so maybe that's a lie
that I just told but I think is they're
like on their 32nd season
I like last year or two years ago I
remember I always like sick or something
or just in one of those sad phases of
life and so I found Bad Girls Club and I
was like oh right I forgot about the
show and I binge like two seasons of it
I felt such anxiety like I couldn't
leave my house because I was just like
walking around me like I can't interact
with anyone because I'm going to get mad
for no reason it may be so like my blood
surge yeah it was a lot of aggression
you know the females and supporting
females man I was like this is
counterproductive we need like a bad
girls club supporting other bad house
where we like take on the man it also
just blew my mind like I know reality TV
evades simple form of television but it
just blew my mind that every episode was
I was like so there's no goal no there's
no goal than just coexisting in this
loft space together and just trying to
keep all your nails on but like they did
try for like a couple seasons times like
a therapist
let's be really bad do you do
bachelor/bachelorette I used to do it
anymore I'm with you I just like I
couldn't like I hate like like Ashley
Ashley Ashley n and yarn teeth they all
look the exact same
always take the same person like it's
just like it's not cute anymore and like
there's something again about like all
fighting for like the same dude that's
just not cute yeah and I guess this
season everyone's upset that they all
keep referring to him as their boyfriend
and it's like but that's not that I mean
he's not your friend yet you don't know
exactly what's the collective amount of
time that you've spent like being in the
same room as him yeah that one I have
fallen off the wagon on it is stressing
me out a little bit but no no I bachelor
in paradise though oh so that's that's a
horse of a different color yeah that's a
free range like you know what I mean
yeah and I feel like they have that show
still has potential for more [ __ ] on
it whereas like I could nurse this whole
time oh yeah you can sorry I also know I
feel bad because you know people that
have backgrounds on Disney and such
children centric networks I didn't ever
want them to feel like my I proxy I'm
gonna be painting your reputation has I
peed in a sink season 1 of on my block
Esmond angel hooray
on camera okay literally I'm not like
method I'm not like really doing it it's
I love this and cute so like yeah no no
I have no couth but yeah bachelor
paradise I think that they still the
desperation that lingers harder there
and so they don't have to orchestrate as
much other than just having a person
show up to create drama rather than like
on The Bachelor it's like now we need to
have this horse-drawn carriage show up
with this country star that you used
today yeah you've never heard of they
always exactly and then this time it's
like oh it was her ex-boyfriend or
something
that's what happened this see I'm only
reading Twitter headlines about it cuz I
haven't watched the episodes but I guess
matters I guess one of those they're to
me no offense to them because the real
artists and music is something I can't
do and appreciate behind all but they're
like the RIA the royalty-free version of
music because it is crazy expensive yeah
and I guess this season the guy that was
doing it was actually like had dated the
girl that he brought into the room to
like dance in front of him nobody knew
that going into it no no but I guess
producers are meddling too much and
everyone's like we see it it's too out
of it because I'm sure like when you're
doing the application it says like the
last five people you've dated name
Social Security they do where they live
I think that's why it's hard to watch
too because you know I you kind of start
to understand how the behind the scenes
works and it just becomes too much
puppeteering like nothing is an organic
moment other than the champagne blowing
up interface well you know what it is
like the best show in the history of the
world what love after lockup alright I
just got into this show three weeks ago
and I watched love after lockup and life
after lockup I spent I gave four days
away to that show that's like because
I'm also a 90 day fiancé
okay thank you very much all of those
married at first sight and then love
after lockup I was like oh this is the
bad girls club of be sure it's the best
it's like my guilty pleasure I am so
obsessed with it my friend mamrie told
me about it and I was like I don't know
that might be too much for me and then I
watched I was like oh no she's right no
because everyone's so different and it's
it's just it's just a disaster
yeah like but there's sometimes sweet
moments but it's mostly just a disaster
and I can't stop looking at it yeah it's
really I'm so glad that you also share
the love of that show absolutely I
should seek help yeah after right
search these are real people just
studying like human behavior yeah I
should have plotted exactly I should get
spectrum for free what do you do it for
in your free time like other than
reality TV or you don't work there are
things I write a lot do you I write so
so much what kind of writing I am I like
to write scripts for myself yeah and I
also like to do them on the back of like
sides of auditions I didn't get I'm
saving paper because I can't type them
out yeah I have to hand write scripts
like it's very bizarre no I get that so
I write a lot I used to actually take
when I was a kid I sit takes scripts off
of like online movies I used to like and
I used to write myself a part in them
that's how I was like what it looks like
me but now they will I mean that's a you
had to create a writing exercise for
yourself like thank you online that's
great dialo so we write we I have a
really great like the friends I was
telling you about
Audrey yeah of them I have like a
ridiculous core group of friends and we
like hang out maybe too much all the
time that's good yeah you guys are also
busy people we are we are cuz you and
Audrey met at Disney yes okay yeah yeah
and she's like a decade younger than me
no it's so fun she's all energy no she
doesn't
okay super Sun she's like this fiery
Aries that's just like I just feel like
she's my child like if I have a daughter
like I hope she's just like her so like
I can like you know I'm taking care of
them mostly there you go
but yeah we'd you know do the things we
paintball sometimes we laser tag
sometimes so you are really living a
teenage lifestyle I mean trying to I
guess again research exactly besides
watching reality shows I'm like what do
i do that's like I mean I feel like I
don't have a personality because that's
all I wanted to do you okay well doing
[ __ ] you know and that being I cause
it's I'm not sure where it's available
now but you have to buy it on Amazon I
think okay cuz I didn't all over the
world we were too hot for teen neck
Teaneck was like oh we didn't read I
feel like every time I see those girls
bounced around to a different like
streaming platform or a television
network it started basically like at
awesomenesstv
like on the internet go 90 yeah go 90
yeah so IP do you participate in
Internet do you I did I did like like
there was a hacking high schools thing I
did for awesomeness did a sleep tight
okay with Keanu ledee we did like I did
little things like that but I don't
really do too much internet things
anymore but you do maintain your social
media and you do all of it - I do which
is really cool to me because in looking
through everything you're not afraid to
hold back about like political beliefs
and I think that's really cool that
you're not censoring yourself thank you
because you want you doing you're being
amazing talented actress but then you're
also being like a real activist in the
world which i think is like very
necessary right now especially for the
kids that are watching your show do you
ever feel scared or intimidated about
being so vocal all the time and I'm just
like but right before I hit Send panic
attacks
I'll read it like 87 times and go and
how can somebody misconstrue that yeah
God and I just tweeted something the
other day that was like pretty good I
was really proud of it and then like I
spelled something wrong and it had
already gotten like you know that amount
of light so it's like gone too far yeah
I say something no but depending on who
retweeted it you're like everyone no I
think it's just necessary 100 percent is
that like it's it there's no there's no
place for complacency right now in our
country in our world like especially if
you have a platform it's it's so
important to be vocal like I mean at
this point like the world's coming for
me like you know what I mean I just know
there's no hiding from that right so I I
think it's really important and I am
scared a little bit but at the same time
like you know I can't look at my future
kids and say well I favorite it a tweet
and that was important it's like no like
I go to marches I do it's great it's
really really important yeah you would
have more regret looking back and not
being as not using your platform as much
as you probably could absolutely
absolutely
do you with like Instagram and stuff do
you have kind of like set rules and how
much you reveal about like your personal
life versus how much you kind of put out
there about anything else um I haven't
really I've been lucky enough I guess to
not be put in a position where I really
had to like think about it like that
really I'm pretty open that's great um
I also try and like live my life to a
place where I don't have to regret
something or feel bad about something so
like whoa I'm pretty open and honestly I
feel like Who I am is trying to stay
like open and honest because I feel like
people respond to that authenticity ya
know then necessarily like oh I'm gonna
make everyone believe that this is who I
am and this is how I am and not the fact
that I'm gonna [ __ ] up all the time yeah
and I'm human and I'm not gonna look
perfect or like that's just not who I am
anyway it's exhausting to die and be
like that oh my god to try and curate so
much of like what looks perfection yeah
like I don't have time to try and get
the same face that everyone is trying to
have it would be exact same but I will
do the get that picture like I'm going
to feel attractive in like one certain
pose like my left side is better so this
is like the most anxiety I've ever had
I'll talk to the back you know yeah it's
just it's important for me to just be
honest and like always call out like you
know that elephant in the room or like
whatever is like bothering you like yeah
so who do you follow if there are any
standouts online who are better or worse
Ashlee Marie Preston is big ones in my
life she has recently come into my life
and I admire her so much so I look to
her for inspiration who also I look up
to America Fiera oh yeah
I follow like everyone really well I
like to I also love like knowing what
people are doing and you know how
they're using their platform
I try not to follow too many people that
are like you know just trying to live
this like unrealistic like motto ask
like that's not really my vibe totally
um but I like following people that are
continuously like being active in their
community that's cool
that makes sense and then also like
musicians and like makeup gurus oh yeah
I mean I'm not perfect you're a huge
kpop fan I do like kpop this is a new
thing for me okay I don't know like
everything but one of my best
girlfriends Millie is like the biggest
kpop fan ever and she like introduced me
and now I'm like okay girl I get it
because I I'm still I'm on an endless
quest but I I'm not being too proactive
at it to learn more about kpop I mean
we've had some you know k-pop people on
the show and yeah Eric Nam and well I
forget I'm so Tablo yeah that we're here
and it's still world that I don't know
much about them very much intimidated by
but I just think it's so badass that
like the meet what some of the music
that's doing the best in this country is
not music from this country right like
that just makes me like I can't wait to
like be in the car and listen to like
different music from all around the
world and having it be like the number
one song like right yeah it's like
that's so telling of like what this
country is you know right do do you do
music I love music I like pretend I can
sing bread crayon are on on my block is
an incredible singer yeah he always
tells me it's like Tesco you can see you
can sing I have like a pretty tone
uh-huh I don't know what the hell I'm
doing it's like either flat or I'm sharp
or like trying way too hard but I do
love it I do love to sing what's your
go-to karaoke song oh I would never do
karaoke in front of people like I'm like
I'm your height man like the ones doing
like left I know I just
karaokes weird to me because it makes
you feel like either like a you have to
pay attention to this person who thinks
they can say yeah or they're also
actually really really good and you feel
like okay we get it you're great
yeah or it's like all over the place in
a way it's a little yeah I I will I will
never be the person to suggest doing
karaoke ever ever ever but I will
participate if I'm in a group of people
that all want to do karaoke
I guess it would depend on how Annie
braided I am at that time true but then
it's also it's just a strange concept to
me because it's basically like a self
moderated talent show yeah like everyone
is volunteering to go prove themselves
to strangers right now I don't want to
be proven anything like there's like
five people out there like yeah like
then it's like I guess I could be fun or
the only times I've really had a good
time is when you rent out that room Oh
like privately and then it's like all
your friends but like at the same time
I'm just like I'm not gonna do like in
my room like I J Matt's like Mariah
Carey like full like with a brush but
you can um okay you recently got a
package from Oprah Winfrey's company I
did well what is what was this I ain't
her book club oh okay very honored hell
is that going it's going great I should
know that was more like that came to me
and I just was like I don't know who I
need to thank for this let's see I yeah
I should be getting my like first one in
like six weeks or something right
congratulate thank you but I got like
pencils and like a note back you know
this is for you and it has oh all over
it so I just stare at it from time to
time
what's been the other than this the the
best swag that you've gotten who or the
the most ridiculous well um lolz sends
send me pre-roll jay-z yeah oh you got
them all the time and then one time oh
my god I'm like seasonally I have to
write them but like weed me never this
is research to I have cramps every day
but that also Netflix for my registry
sent me like there's a huge luggage set
which that was like really insane and it
was like something like they didn't send
the rest that casket we always get like
things that's a cast I like posting
Emily thanks Netflix haha right Jason
you know yeah you got married last year
October 2018 Wow congratulations
how was that it was beautiful it was
like really chaotic though my mom had a
heart attack eight weeks before my
wedding oh wow and almost lost her so
like I was like a zombie until like I
was walking down the aisle and tell my
husband thankfully she's here she's good
all the woods to everyone but no she's
kicking ass but it was really like that
time was super intense yeah like I
really wanted to celebrate and have some
fun but like at the same time in your
head you're like oh my god you're like
waiting for that next you know yeah so
it was a little crazy but the actual day
was unbelievable that's incredible how
long have you and your husband known
each other
11 years Wow very short amount of time
you got one of those long loves what
took so long
well weddings are expensive hmm yes yes
yes and I wanted everything and the fact
that working out here you're never gonna
fully know your schedule for when we
died no I was filming while we were
doing a second season or if I was
filming I was getting married while we
were shooting season two
yeah like the whole cast drove out to
because we got married in Riverside so
from Burbank drove out and a lot of them
had to drive back that next her like
that night to go to work to get go to
work and like there was like a whole
talk there like you will not get to turn
at Jessica's wedding it was amazing it
was my favorite moment oh if you know
crying no no it was his first wedding
too Wow so he was like pretending like
it's fine it's fine it's fine everything
I don't care it was not real and you
like crying
that's so sweet what a great gift to you
they're pretty amazing
oh that's wonderful okay we're gonna
take one last break when we get back we
have a lot of really great Twitter
questions for you we'll be right back
with more not your deep
[Music]
- hey guys it's your friend grace helbig
here the host of the podcast that you
are currently listening to and hopefully
enjoying maybe even enough to leave a
review on Apple podcasts it helps people
find the podcast share all of the
entertainment spread the joy spread the
pants shooting stories you get it if you
go over to Apple podcasts leave a
beautiful or dumb review either way both
help and hopefully you continue to enjoy
what's your hearing
thanks okay we're back and Jessica
before we get into these Twitter
questions I'm gonna ask you the two
questions asked every single guest that
is on the podcast and the first is who
alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at Fidel Castro oh
okay I don't think we've ever had that
answer Cuban okay the other question I
ask every single guest is to tell us
your worst pants [ __ ] story or close
call but you can only use three words or
three small phrases so mine is college
jogging front lawn first school day sois
first school day first school day I
think you said first school gay first
school day oh it's not that great no but
it's it's in line with a lot of stories
have involved school in some way because
that's you know your stomach is awry
yeah
I have to give my three words warning
okay let's get into these Twitter
questions someone wants to know what's
your favorite behind-the-scenes memory
from all my blocks ooh oh I have so many
I think I'm one of the ones that make me
laugh the most is shooting a second
season with Bret there's a scene with
shoshanna's character amber and where
he's saying okay bye amber and he's
supposed to be like throwing her like
just saying like whatever like stringing
her off so he called her every white
girl's name he could think of after
every take just trying to make me laugh
so it was like okay Heather and you look
at me okay Jasmine okay okay okay like
it was just funny it's like I'm like
crying laughing to the point where
they're like okay guys like together
it's one line like we you know you shoot
for so long that you just become
delirious oh you get the giggles
and Bret sings everything so it's like
it doesn't matter what time of day it is
he's singing his lines any song you've
ever said do you guys get the
opportunity to post a lot behind the
scenes or do they try and regulate that
oh they regulate it so hard really they
don't want to or anything like even if
we like post something from that day and
we're not wearing our clothes and maybe
like my hair is curled in a Jasmine way
they're like what is this a joke
wow that's interesting yeah cuz I mean
obviously they don't want spoilers but
you know obviously you also want to be
like but I want to show something like
you're right I haven't done anything for
ten weeks seeing a soul and someone says
ask her what her favorite type of bean
is please please please
ooh like like a food bean is there
another bean I would say Sean Bean Sean
Bean sausage no um black bean okay yeah
there you go
now they got their answer are you
cooking for me I can it won't be good I
can how was it behind the scenes at
Disney oh so fun like it's so funny
because like I I have the opposite of
like a drama Disney like oh yeah like it
was a perfection so
feels like um what's well what's the
difference between that and
behind-the-scenes now um I hanging on
them being on a multicam show you have
like a you know a studio so they are
like centrally located to everybody at
all times
yeah so like I could be in dubs dressing
room I could be in Joey's dressing room
like you always have like the same ones
yeah but when you are shooting on like a
single cam you're always like half of
you are on set doing this and other ones
on location doing this like you're
separated a lot so with Disney you were
able to kind of have more of like a
middle school high school like we put
like a video game system in Joey's room
like you know it's stuff like that we
were doing pranks on each other we're
like on my block it still feels like you
know we're adults like younger like
there was like we were straight up like
a summer camp but exactly yeah and like
even everyone on our show like
production-wise was like guys it's not
typically like this are so rare cuz like
we were all like there was not like a
bad egg like everything was amazing yeah
yeah I guess that's true because you do
hear that Disney could go either way
oh yeah you always say the horror story
yeah that just was like really not like
I went in right yeah did you have any
anxiety before going yeah yeah you know
like I just like I had never met dove in
the day that I met dove I was like why
is this angelic most beautiful girl you
have ever seen in your life like
floating to me right like she jumped in
my arms I also thought I was 15 which
was hilarious she was like oh you're
just a kid she thought she was older
than me which is so true
but no it was just it was beautiful it
was really perfect it was really a great
you know moment in time for my career
where like things were like you know
beginning to take off feel like we're in
a very comfortable place because that's
so not always right ya know that's
really magical to hear because it could
like you said we're Joey and I earned
this huge feud someone to know how is
married life married life is great has
anything shifted there's a kind of
the same it's actually it feels a lot
the same yeah I know we were calling he
kind of other husband-and-wife way
before just because like he would talk
to like people on the phone like sales
people and they say I have to talk to my
wife she was like you're not my
girlfriend like fiance always felt so
pretentious to me yeah like I couldn't
help being like oh my fiance
waiting for you to them congratulate me
yeah like it's just so like fiance I
just hated that yeah so like husband and
wife sounds so much better but like yeah
he's like he's my person yeah I mean I'm
assuming he supports everything oh yeah
you could get into he's also like such a
SAP like he's 64 300 pounds but like he
cries on a puppy anything that like he's
just so he's the best so I he's been so
ridiculously supportive and like I'm so
emotional on this ride yeah that's great
that's very sweet
okay if someone says how weird is it to
be so young and have already
participated in something with the
cultural relevance of on my block again
I am so young skin routine coming up
next it's it really is unbelievable you
know it's something that I don't take
lightly yeah I know there you feel a lot
of responsibility in a role that that is
affecting the youth so so much it's
still overwhelming like when people come
up to me and tears or you know like I
didn't see myself and anyone before
jasmine or like you know it's it's
really humbling because you feel like
you know Jasmine's not necessarily my
story but if you feel like I'm doing
that justice like that means the world
to me
that's enough so no I'm just you know I
just hope that they continue to love it
keep watching tell everyone else to
watch it and I've heard recently that
you need to finish it for Netflix to
give you more I'm gonna do your
completion rate is 100% the situation
yes complete what you've started you
have a mission you had a mission I will
be giving you a test what's your
favorite pizza or pizza place rather I
don't really have a favorite pizza place
I saw this question I thought about it
yeah I feel like I need to like say like
a super like cool mom and
please like I'm like oh my god she's so
charming but like edgy and like goes out
for a little guy like I wanted that but
at the same time I'm like little caesars
it's delicious yeah yeah Canton I also
am on keto so like I can't really talk
about pizza right now I get a house key
Togo and great I'm like down so many
like besides it congratulations
yeah how do you think ketosis yes that's
the it's the craziest thing to me it's
like a science experiment it is do you
pee on the stick so if I know if you're
in ketosis still no when were you
supposed to do that oh my friend told me
she must be really weird 23andme that I
have not heard she might have been
telling me that she's not pregnant I
don't know I bet she's trying to tell me
that keto you're like I'm not in ketosis
so a little Russian but kudos to I hear
it works wonders for people and just
gives you energy my energy is really
good that's cool yeah I I supplement
keto with Red Bull what was your first
impression of the live in Maddy cast oh
they were amazing and fun and probably
like not too cool for me but that wasn't
the case but it's also crazy too because
I don't think people think about
sometimes when you walk into a cast and
you're the new girl on the block for
lack of a better word that there's an
intimidation there because these people
have been working together and it's also
like you show up with a job to do yeah
that's nuts to me they like especially
because they were a show called bits and
pieces okay before there were Liv and
Maddie so they had like promoted and
done a whole pilot for this series and a
Disney was like I don't know about this
series but I love these people okay so
like that's when they formed Liv and
Maddie so I was really coming into it a
year after all these people had been
together and you know as a guest start
to like you honestly for me at least
always feel dispensable like I always
feel like you know they can call you
this week but they might not call you
next week like I waited tables all three
well first three seasons of Liv and
Maddie because I was like I can't afford
to not work next week right and like I
would be giving people their burgers and
taking pictures with their kids
there must have been some work no I
happened all the time oh that's so
fascinating but that's true yeah there's
nothing guaranteed mm-hmm so you get a
fun little anxiety cloud to live in in
between I just work there is no shame in
working like yeah I will you know hope
to god never have to do that again but
like if I did I would you know I'm
really gonna good for you I mean it also
keeps you humble to to realize like yeah
I'm going to do what I have to do just
do it I mean I just have seen so many
people you know want this more than me
more talented than me and Warren as a
successful right so you know how
fleeting it can be so it's like it's
just really important to be you know
grateful that's a great attitude
speaking of serious topics like this
what's your favorite dipping sauce
whoo all of them I am well food is my
favorite subject in general yeah and I'm
a saucy broad so I would say like I love
any like sweet salty so like sweet chili
or like a sweet and sour always ranch I
love like honey mustard stuff like that
but I always kind of go for like the
like that a 10-year okay okay well
hopefully that person has fully assessed
your personality because they said it's
number one way to judge someone's
personality oh [ __ ] I failed okay
chunky blue cheese or nothing okay all
my blocks season three is coming up and
despite us seeing so many different
aspects of Jasmine in the last season
what's something that you want to see I
want to see her loyalty and her
friendship reciprocated more than
anything I think there are a lot of kids
that see themselves in Jasmine because
they are very loyal and they and it's
hard to make friends sometimes yeah and
you know overcompensating with maybe a
bigger personality or like a jokester
like a class clown in order to obtain
those friends and I feel like she's
going to hopefully get more
reciprocation after she showed more
sides of her oh yeah so I hope that kids
are able to see that like you know if
you are more of yourself and less of
like a representative you might you know
might be easier to make friends that's
great that's a great message break down
those walls a little bit robots or
aliens aliens whoo 100% aliens in terms
of like which one you'd like to spend
more time
with anything really I think any answer
I would say aliens because robots to me
are more terrifying yeah he says like
they have no feelings and if you're also
putting in feelings that's like a whole
other situation I just think if I robot
and like Will Smith and I'm like no he
says no I say no like aliens Will Smith
like he did well you got to switch out
Jeff Goldblum for Shia Wow
yeah I agree I think that aliens are
here to come in peace I think robots I
hope so maybe like robots are gonna you
know pretend that they're coming here in
peace and then develop some higher
intelligence and really really possibly
humans are the ones making robots and
humans are terrifying and aliens like
you know are like you know God probably
made them a right way to same one that
is whole other thing I'm down here we
all talk about it I love to have them on
the podcast and this might be a little
we told you Netflix is listening Thunder
buddy
what is the Thunder buddy is Thunder
buddy like Ted Thunder buddy like Mark
Wahlberg Ted Thunder buddy what is that
like okay I know this was like a Disney
reference no it's not is not Ted is not
a Disney character okay okay my Thunder
buddy well I mean it would be a real
buddy and it would be my husband if not
it would be my dog yeah Oh what kind of
dog do you have
she's a corgi pitbull wow it looks like
a tiny little she's 500 see what's her
name Lady perfect cuz she does this oh
that's so cute
ever heard of a corgi pitbull oh my god
it's crazy like I never put her in water
cuz I'm scared she'll just like she's a
meatloaf with legs and they're only like
three inches oh my god I mean she sounds
hilarious
she's so cute oh okay and this is our
last question which kind of leads into
two everything should we be expecting
you and other projects dropping soon
besides on my block what do you have
coming up waited what's down the horizon
are you not entertained
do you get to take a break no it's so
funny because like I always feel like
that not all actors get that they're
like I just did three movies and a
series what else am i doing well not
right I am working on things for myself
especially when I'm not working so
hopefully those things will plan out but
would you ever do a reality show that
follows your life around not for like
unless I got a lot of money just because
like oh my god my husband would hate it
right yeah so I don't really know how
entertaining it would be um I think I
would like to like maybe one day host
something or like being judged on
something that'd be cool because I love
pretending I know things about
everything of course I could totally
judge America's Next Top Model I've
watched it so many times like I know Top
Chef totally I wanna be drag race judge
so bad but I would also be so way too
intimidated to do it oh I would be too
they would be like I'm looking at the
way you did your makeup like what are
you doing let you in like No agreed I
think I would love to but I I could see
you judging reality-competition contest
very very easily thank you I would like
to do that but right now season three is
out right so everyone's encouraged to go
well it's not out yet not out yeah it
should be soonish soonish perfect did
you see that move did you see how quick
like Netflix was like on the phone
there's a red phone that should give a
date so Jessica thank you so much for
being here
thank you for having before you go
everyone that is a guest on the podcast
gets a personalized fortune cookie from
us to you you don't eat it cuz I don't
know if it falls in line with Kido
but yeah no worries I don't encourage
anyone whether they're in ketosis or not
to eat these fortune cookie just be
specifically because I love fortune
cookies they're totally fine they're
very edible but they just come from a
box from Amazon yes of course
I don't have a fortune that's like not a
great size yeah uh uh I jumped out it
was like you really scared to give this
to me oh oh oh my goodness MTV Awards
has been altered about alerted about you
stealing table centerpiece they say they
understand it accept a loss and
hopefully will do better by you next
year 100% MTV they heard they knew how
did you get it out you put it in your
purse first of all it was about the size
of this baby that's right here okay it
was like a tube and I picked it up and
there was like a security like officer
right there and I was like I lost to
Lady Gaga I'm taking this and he said I
didn't see anything and I was like
that's right and then like the whole
castle of hip-hop was like are those new
words I was like no they were like just
working people find you if they don't
know on the internet Oh in the valley on
the interwebs on Instagram I am at Jess
underscore M okay underscore Garcia
there are a lot of people with my name
not because they want to be me just
they're genuinely Jessica Garcia and on
Twitter at Jess my Garcia okay very cool
guys go check her out and make sure on
my block when it comes back for season
three watch it all the way through yes
the first day it's out at midnight yeah
you've done it for there you go there
you go thank you again for making time
for us thank you for having me
hoarse and we'll see you guys next time
on another episode of not too deep
goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep not too
deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa D months
edited by
Shareen lani unis post production sound
by Chris Henry and an extra special
thanks to Flula for the theme music
[Music]